hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
consider the following diagram
the blue circle's radius is 4 and the
green circle's radius is 2.
the line is tangent to all three circles
and the three circles touch each other
they are pairwise tangent
what is the radius of the white circle
i thank devin from indonesia at the
lilin bangsa intercultural school for
suggesting this problem
it was a challenge problem for students
aged 14 and 15.
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
well it will involve connecting the
centers of these circles
the large circle has a radius of four
the next largest circle has a radius of
two and will label the third circle's
radius as little r
now we can create three different right
triangles by connecting the centers of
the circles
the first triangle will connect the
center of this small circle to the
center of the circle with radius of four
this will be a right triangle
its hypotenuse will be the sum of the
two radii it will be four plus r
one of its legs will be the difference
between four and r so that'll be 4 minus
r
the other leg of this triangle we can
solve using the pythagorean theorem
this will be the square root of the
quantity 4 plus r squared minus the
quantity 4 minus r squared we can
simplify this to be four times the
square root of r
now we can do a similar thing with the
other circle that is a radius of two
its hypotenuse will be two plus r one of
its legs will be two minus r and we can
solve for the length of the other leg
using the pythagorean theorem
it'll be a similar calculation and we'll
get this is two times the square root of
two multiplied by the square root of r
now there's one more right triangle to
consider this will connect the centers
of the two larger circles
the hypotenuse will be the sum of the
radii
4 plus two is equal to six
one leg will be four minus two and
that's equal to two
other leg is parallel to the two lengths
at the bottom
so this will be
square root of r times the quantity four
plus two times the square root of two
we can then use the pythagorean theorem
and we'll get six squared minus two
squared is equal to the square of this
other leg
we then do some algebra and simplify it
and now you're going to divide by 4 plus
2 times the square root of 2 squared now
in order to simplify that you can
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by 4 minus 2 times the
square root of 2 squared
and you'll end up rationalizing this
fraction and you'll get that r is equal
to 12 minus 8 times the square root of 2
and that's our answer
so that's our answer for these specific
lengths
but can we generalize this
what would happen if our two larger
circles had arbitrary values
well we can modify this diagram as
follows suppose the largest circle has a
radius of capital r one
and the next largest circle has a radius
of capital r sub two
we still have the following three
triangles and we can figure out the
lengths of each of these sides as we
just did before
the hypotenuse of each triangle will be
the sum of the two radii
one leg will be the difference of the
radii
and we can solve for the other leg using
the pythagorean theorem
in this case we'll just label it as x1
and we could set up the following
equation using the pythagorean theorem
we'll do the same thing for the green
triangle
we have x2 expressed using the
pythagorean theorem
and now in this third triangle which is
in purple
we can solve for this leg as the sum of
x1 plus x2 and we can also use the
pythagorean theorem
now with some effort we can solve for r
little r that is and we'll get the
following equation
1 divided by the square root of r is
equal to 1 divided by the square root of
r1
plus 1 divided by the square root of r2
and like magic we figured out an
equation that we can solve for little r
regardless of the values of big r1 and
big r2
tremendous
did you figure it out and did you solve
for this general relationship
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free inspire
and build confidence for people around
the world and they already have over a
hundred million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can map the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos email me a
puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com and if you so
choose you can check out my books which
are listed in the video description and
you can support me on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support